[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 186 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
my name is Mark mantle and I'm very
excited to be joined today by cotton
walking
how're you doing today kata I'm doing
well mark yeah it's good to be here yeah
so glad to have you on the podcast it's
your first time here so you want to give
people a little intro to yourself and
what you do yeah it's actually my first
time since I got back because I was here
like two three years ago yeah developer
advocate though so I'm here and I just
make videos and I just make videos about
everything Google cloud related and
specifically VMs in GC coming up pretty
soon I'm just actually trying to
remember you were on the podcast a while
ago like a long time kubernetes 1.33
yeah yeah yeah okay so so you're not
stranger it's fine it's fine
been here done that so today we're go to
a really cool topic we are gonna talk
about blockchain we develop our advocate
island day which I'm kind of excited
about you know hot topic but also kind
of interesting I know so little about
blockchain it's time to learn it's like
time to figure this out yeah yeah it's
gonna be it's gonna be fun and then
after that we have our question of the
week as per always I'm gonna ask Carter
about vm's
what are the four types of virtual
machines that exist on Google cloud
platform
oh and trigger intriguing but before we
do that why don't we get stuck into our
cool things of the week
[Applause]
we have to hear that blockchain today so
it is actually quite apropos that
there's an article talking about
blockchain comm scaling and saving with
a cloud spanner so blockchain comm is
our website that serves at the
cryptocurrency blockchain or really
unsurprisingly and it is helped 39
million cross-platform Wallet users in
140 countries worldwide access the
crypto ecosystem and they've been using
our horizontally scalable database
spanner to basically help them with
their needs in managing what is
essentially money which is you know kind
of important to some people so if you
want to see some details about what it
is they've been doing and how they've
been using it make sure to check out the
article which will happen the shirt it
ok that was cool but what about winning
AI Records and competitions
I suppose that's alright that's pretty
cool so Google Cloud recently was in a
competition and they set three new
performance records and the latest round
of the m/l perf benchmark competition so
this is like an industry-wide standard
for measuring m/l performance and so
it's cool because like things like
object detection or a natural language
modeling or what these algorithms are
used for in Google Cloud CPUs do it very
fast like over 84 percent faster than
the fastest on-premise systems in the ML
Perce clothes division so I thought that
was really cool there's a whole article
about it on cloud.google.com called
cloud TPU pod breaks ai training records
definitely check that out very nice so
we have some updates as well to cloud
memory store for Redis our fully managed
Redis service so if you were looking for
Redis 4.0 support that is now available
also what we have available is the new
import/export feature so you're able to
import an export out of a cloud storage
bucket of your choosing so you can
basically get your data in and out of
Redis really easily just do really nice
features that are super nice to talk
about
that's very cool all right features that
are nice to talk about let's go back to
kubernetes and being able to customize
kubernetes to fit your needs so there's
this article that came out to run or not
to run a database on kubernetes and they
basically talked about how if you can't
find something like a fully managed
database like cloud spanner or if you
don't want to do it yourself on a VM how
you can do it on kubernetes using
operators so you can make basically
custom code to run and help you manage
this database so that I think is super
cool you know why not customize the
database to fit exactly what you need
for your application
you can check that out in this article
yeah I really like the flow chart and
the article as well where it's focus
about like this is how you can easily
make the decision about where you should
put your database so I thought that was
super nice finally we want to just say
congratulations to a last a file we want
to announce that Google has entered into
a definitive agreement to acquire elasto
file they are an enterprise to file
storage for the cloud basically lovely
scalable file storage we actually have a
lust to file file service on GCP which
is a fully managed version of Alessa
file integrated with Google cloud and we
have similar customers already using it
but super excited to have them on board
and joining the Google cloud family
Congrats a lasso file excellent awesome
well Carter why don't we go chat with
Alan and learn all about blockchain
I can't wait let's do this
[Music]
so very excited to have Alan day here
developer advocate for data science and
verticals joining us Alan how are you
doing today yeah thanks so much for
joining us you've come today to talk to
us about blockchain which should be kind
of fun but before we get stuck into that
do you want to tell us a little bit
about yourself who you are what do you
do here at Google my name's Alan I'm a
developer advocate products that would
be big query and pub/sub and data flow
and BigTable and any of the computer
storage resources for processing and
analyzing large volumes of fast-moving
data my PhD is in human genetics so I
have a background in biological data
types like um sequencing and medical
imaging and that's part of what I do at
Google and then I also cover blockchains
and cryptocurrencies
because I'm based in Singapore and
that's one of the more advanced
regulatory jurisdictions for this type
of technology
it's Singapore in Switzerland are the
two hot bits of activity for
incorporating and making a foundation
and so on so I figured I could do work
locally by focusing on this industry and
it's been going pretty well that's
that's exciting me here Wow very
technical stuff too so then just the
question I have is unlike a day-to-day
you know developer advocate what do you
do in these areas are you making videos
or yeah sometimes I used to do a lot of
events and I know that part of leaders
where I'm showing up soon but it's it's
less than I used to being out in the
field I can do a lot more writing these
days I find it's just better to have my
time blocked like that with less
switching cost of moving around about
losing days during travel I could do
more focused deep work and then that
also lets me spend more by interrupts
time doing coordination with with others
the cryptocurrency datas which is most
people I'm working with it's public data
that we can index like just with Google
indexes the web and so as a result all
the work that I'm doing is open source
development and it's with distributed
open source teams of contributors were
all have some business interests but are
also volunteering time killed
open source repos an open source
datasets and so there's a lot of
interrupts I'm dedicated to team
coordination herding cats so all of that
sounds amazing but why don't we
when we start at a high level and like
working our way down all the way through
the chain which sounds really cool but
now that sounds awesome though
so like okay what is blockchain because
I actually have no idea it's a word that
gets thrown around a lot especially here
in the Bay Area that's like where you
are as well so like what is this thing
that we keep hearing about everywhere
most of the audience should be familiar
with something called BitTorrent which
is protocol KC I see your hits or
nothing it's a protocol for a bunch of
peer-to-peer technologies in general
which is have a distributed system so
these peers get together and they're
trying to solve some problem like make
sure everybody has the same copy of the
file or in the case of this blockchain
they're trying to make sure everybody
agrees that the latest set of
transactions that are being added on to
the end of a long file or agreed upon by
everybody that that's really what is in
the latest block so there's some
consensus algorithm essentially being
reached by a group of peers to Gordon
eight work hmm anybody like that how
does that kind of work in terms of we
talk about data structures that's
probably the easiest way yeah like do
you and I just chat and I'm just like
it's cool and you're like it's cool and
then we just go in our separate ways or
is there like some sort of like contract
or or like what does that look like
so there's many of these different
blocks and implementations but at the
most basic level they're using a
cryptographic function a hashing
function right where the the output is
deterministic based on the input but
it's not predictable because the outputs
appear to be uniformly distributed
relative to whatever input dudn't which
means that for a given input and output
a peer on the network can verify that
the output is what it ought to be based
on the inputs you can match them but in
order to find a particular output based
on the input is difficult because the
outputs are uniformly distributed
relative to the input it's random
essentially okay so what that means is
that if we try to reduce the entropy of
the output like by let's say we have a
big vector of 256 bits and we're trying
to make the first bit zero okay that's
really easy that's 50 percent of the
time but if you try to make the first 10
bits zero over the first hundred bits to
zero it becomes a lot more difficult to
find that given that you have to do a
search basically just by throwing darts
at a board just because you've got 99
zeros and
place you can't move directly next door
and get a hundred it's this could be
back to one one zero God so what these
piers do is that they look at how long
it took to find a solution for a
particular number of zeros to omit a
block in a particular amount of time so
it's basically said with some computing
power being consumed over time which
they call a hash rate so how many of
these hashing functions can be done per
unit time and if a solution was found
too quickly then the peers agreed
because they're all sharing the same
code base that the difficulty should be
increased we now need to add more zeros
to make it slower or if it was found too
slowly then we make it an easier problem
to solve and so this is how they're
doing the agreement some peers are
giving this hashing to search for
solutions to make a block within a
particular amount of time and they're
adjusting the difficulty more or less
based on how close they are to the
desired amount of time okay okay so now
let's talk about what is this block all
about so yep what are they trying to
agree about the block contains a set of
transactions so each of the entities
that is participating on the pretty much
ripped up currencies down this is think
it simple a Bitcoin anybody can generate
a key pair this is just like the same
kind of key pair you use for PGP or SSH
or SSL same thing so you didn't really
keep air and your private key can't
produce the public keys that's
deterministic you can get the public key
directly from the private key but you
can't get the private key directly from
the public key so what you do is you
share activities that you're interested
to do by signing them with your private
key which is then verifiable that it
corresponds to your public key in a side
transaction that you want to enter onto
the like this log file so the blocks
consists of a series of transactions
that are essentially entries in a log
file all the records which are these
transfers of value like moving Bitcoin
from party at a party v those transfer
operations are all grouped together in a
block and the block is a transaction
like in sequel reads they begin and then
commit the commit is like that so all
the transfers within the same block have
the same timestamp so very much like if
I was in a bank and I was like I want to
move money from here to here and like
between two accounts that's why you need
multiple transactions well essentially
it's one transaction where in one
account is removing something in one
account is adding some
but at the same time correct but in a
way that is it distributed I'm guessing
it's like a peer-to-peer system that is
able to say okay I know that this
happened and we all know that this
happened and we can verify this at a
later date that we all agree on yeah
interesting here so I'm talking about
hash rates earlier and so the incentive
for these computers to be doing the
hashing is that what they will do as
part of their have to find a solution to
this hashing problem on a block right is
they will include their own transaction
to give themselves new bitcoins as part
of that block so if they produce the
block their block contains a block
reward that produces new bitcoins that
go to the rater of the block that it's
been broadcasting on to the network and
so that particular transfer is a special
type of transfer call to coinbase
transaction which is where a few furtive
coinbase which is the biggest exchange
in the u.s. for doing the currency
activity and so the idea there is to
incentivize people allowing you to use
their computers perform these hat
operations that's correct yeah because
you can mint new cryptocurrency by doing
the hashing mmm very cool so I got a
question where you were saying basically
before we're talking about
cryptocurrency before that we were
talking about basically streaming video
and you said that you have a background
and biomedical in agricultural so can
you use this for that as well are there
applications in those areas yes there
are some open source projects in this
blockchain space that are working on
streaming video applications something
like a CDN as well as doing distributed
file storage which would be linked with
a like believe here to here Google Cloud
Storage equivalent biomedically there
are some companies that are working on
making data audible by the user so if
your data are encrypted according to a
private key that only you control then
you can decide who has access to it at
what level it will time and can revoke
access based on your encryption of your
own data oh that is cool yeah there's
various ways you can do this creating
new keys and reprinting or doing multi
signature keys where more than one party
has to sign in order to get access to
some data this is also possible yeah so
there's applications like that for
analytical applications which is where a
lot of what DCP is doing for biomedical
kind of things there's not really any
good way to partition the computing to
shard it is what these distributed
systems people call it to make the
computations cost-effective relative to
a centralized clock this would be for
doing like a deep learning model of
retinopathy or a breast cancer detection
or something like that it's it's just
not really a tractable problem right now
given the architecture of the period
resistance well it sounds like then that
there's there's actually a wide variety
of use cases for blockchain outside of
cryptocurrency is what I'm hearing it's
true yeah any place where you want to
have the immutable data or you can prove
that it was produced and nobody tampered
with it that's a good place for you to
want to use some of this technology so
with all this fake new stuff that's
going on like all really good
applications so then I mean if there's
so many use cases for this it's kind of
strange because I've heard of blockchain
a lot and people joke about it like
every startup has a new block chain or
cryptocurrency offering and so why is it
that this is sometimes people take light
of so much nothing people make so much
fun of a couple of dynamics here so the
point is the granddaddy of all these
things and the Bitcoin community and
enthusiasts have their own strong
culture that has some political ideology
associated with it it's very similar to
the gold bugs where this like finite
supply you can inflate it and it runs
contrary to how mainstream
macroeconomics work and how stiffle
banks operate and so it's a different
kind of thing and because it looks
different it's ridiculed the other
aspect of this is that Bitcoin has been
having some success and aetherium has
been having some success which is
another cryptocurrency and smart contact
platform we can talk about but as a
result of that on a theory you could
actually mint different types of tokens
which are not a first-class
cryptocurrency in their own right but
they can have cryptocurrency like
attribute so that they can be created
and traded and so because there were
enough users using this thing some
clever marketers figured out they could
start doing purely financial and
marketing projects that didn't have much
technical basis or merit for solving any
problems they could just create a token
in IC o---- it and
while ammo and there was a bunch of that
happened to 2017 and a lot of people got
burned by that so that's another reason
things are really cool that's fun
definitely I'm in the same camp as
Carter where I've been you know told if
you want 5% extra evaluation make sure
that blockchains in your startup title
the description about one of these iced
tea manufacturers following its like
blocked a nicety in the stock went up
overnight by you know double duty
percent getting back to more functional
type of things so we talked a little bit
about like what blockchain is good at
and maybe it's also kind of relevant
since we're saying like you know people
feel like they can apply it to anything
but what does look a bad at like what's
it not good for I've heard of people
like saying things like oh we're gonna
use blockchain for database it's like is
that a terrible idea I have no idea okay
so basically all these things boil down
to being log files that have some
mechanism of reaching consensus about
what the contents of the log file are
using a group of peers that may
completely not trust one another or may
have some level of trust between one
another I'm guessing that trustees sort
of implementation detail that's where
you have a public chain or a permission
to chain it's also related to trust and
so yeah so if you have a situation where
you need a log file that can't be
tampered with you have a use case but if
you want to do something like search the
log file to find old records it's not a
use case for that because it's really
just adding things onto the end of a
list that's really what the primary
concern is of one of these consensus
transaction heading systems service you
could I'm thinking through like
communication type stuff like I send you
a message you know it comes from me you
know the messages came in the order that
they came in like that would be a fit
yeah but realized that every one of
these messages has to be added into
something that all the peers are
validating so it could be that there's
some throughput problems with this it's
more more i/o so this is a another
scaling difficulty systems there are
some ways around it using things like
zero knowledge proof sand other
cryptographic stuff but that's outside
the scope we'll talk about today and
it's not clear that that will even be
deployable into product
large-scale anyway but I connect to
something so I was talking about like
okay it's really good for adding entries
to the log file right putting my data
science hat on I was looking for some
kind of thing I could write about as a
developer advocate to get people excited
about working on Google Cloud and I
wanted to do some network analysis of
how all these parties are interacting
with one another on the Bitcoin
blockchain araignee blockchain for that
matter who's sending money to whom and
when and how much and can we figure
anything out about are there any
patterns here can we identify the
exchanges can we identify you know big
owners high throughput nodes etc these
type of questions are very similar to
the kind of questions that I was
addressing in my dissertation work
because genetic regulatory networks have
the same kind of characteristics so
there's some information in the form of
structured molecules coming into a cell
that are food basically or parts to help
the cell run and then there's some waste
molecules that are being thrown out and
then everything in between has to do
with a bunch of proteins and other
molecules that are parts of the cell
that allow that highly structured
material to keep the cell running and
turn into the exhaust and so how does
that regulation work well the way we go
about analyzing it is by collecting some
data using a biochemical assay of some
sort typically very high throughput one
and then we look at the data over time
to see what's going on and that type of
analysis requires all this network
analysis methodology which could be
directly applied to crypto economic
networks I'm thinking okay this would be
great if I can just take some of these
things I already know how to do and
apply it to this other data set that's
getting a lot of attention right now
because nobody is talking about economic
network analysis of these systems
they're just talking about you know I
ceiling making tokens right what is IC
o---- stanford initial coin offering
it's like an IPO got it yeah so I tried
to do this and because I didn't know
anything about any of this stuff about a
year and a half ago so I tried to go and
get the data from the Bitcoin node is
like well I can't again the data why
can't I query it so that I can do an
aggregation over time to look at
what is the limit transaction over time
there's no way to do this so okay well I
guess I can ETL this out into bigquery
and query it and so that took a lot more
time than I thought it would take and
justified writing a blog post about just
doing that and giving back away because
it was really hard to do so I did that
and everybody was very happy about it
and will started using the Danis I think
a lot of traction on our public dataset
program as a result and so because of
that I haven't really done any analysis
I work with a bunch of analysts now but
mostly I'm focused on building the
infrastructure to support other analysts
right
okay now I'm curious GCP specifically
what kind of things do we have that help
with that you said you did some ETL
analysis so that sounds like stackdriver
or something like that maybe yeah so how
we have things set up right now this is
all in github oops anybody wants to grab
the code to replicate this in Amazon or
wherever else at all work we're using
kubernetes to run the blockchain nodes
and we have health checks and load
balancers in place so that if one of our
peers falls over we fail over to the
other one and then there is a clog
composer service that is polling the
blockchain nodes periodically to get
data out when a new block shows up we
stick it into a pub subtopic we publish
to the topic and then there's a
subscriber to the topic that streams the
data into bigquery so we make the
bigquery tables available to users to
query but if they also want to subscribe
to the stream of events those topics are
also public so people who want to do
like real time training based on events
that will is publishing to the topic
they could do that if they want to do
just so I'm clear as often nodes how are
they getting that information is not
like the centralized repository or some
kind or the ones that were running on
kubernetes yeah so when you turn on the
Bitcoin node it connects to its
peer-to-peer network oh it's a
bootstrapping process right got it so
you sort of become one with the mesh
network you'll pick on one of the peers
and all the peers start sending you old
data until you're fully synched with all
the peers and then if you want to you
can start producing new blocks by mining
we don't do any mining though we were
just receiving and Trey
submitting existing chain data to be a
good citizen on the peer-to-peer network
but we're not actually minding any
cryptocurrency I need to look this up
right now that sounds so cool not
everyday but it's more than once a week
I get pinged by somebody who's done
something interesting with this data set
some kind of analysis well yeah what
sunny interesting things that people
found the most interesting things are
related to basically characterizing
entities on the network so it's
pseudonymous right so you may give an
actor on the network has a private key
that's private and then they're signing
transactions so you can verify what
their public identity is but beyond that
you have no idea how any given actor
corresponds to any other actor but if
you start looking at patterns of
activity over time you can begin to get
some sense of what attributes could
belong to a particular actor on the
network let's say there's an O that's
receiving a lot of inputs from many
different other addresses and is
outputting to many other addresses this
is some kind of flow node that has a
high throughput it's typically in
exchange where people are going to trade
tokens for example yeah so this is a
direction we're heading right now so
we've made the bigquery tables available
that was the first thing and we've done
this for eight different block chains at
this point Bitcoin in theory and bunch
of other ones then we made the pub
subtopics available so people can
subscribe to that I'm now working on two
additional fronts so one of them is data
flows where the pub subtopics will be
read by a data flow and output to
another pub subtopic for producing
derivatives so we could basically do
some kind of sliding window analysis run
it all the time and just published into
the topic periodically for making like a
candlestick chart if you wanted to see
something like you know amount of
activity on net worth over time the
other one is really - what Reed is
talking about about analyzing the
network possibly also in real-time where
we can find anomalous transactions or
find labels on entities that are
changing where the entity has some
significant volume through it and these
type of events of turning the continuous
data into discrete data are actually a
way to take the graph the crypto
economic graph and vectorize it so now
we have a vectorized graph and we can
start applying standard machine learning
models onto this because we're now
working in a vector space as opposed to
a high dimensional graph space so I'm
planning on putting all that in BigTable
and doing cool tensor flow stuff on top
of that also inside of dataflow well so
this is such a complex topic and
something you said earlier really
shocked me you said you know a year and
a half ago you didn't know too much
about this so you had to ramp up are the
resources you maybe recommend to people
who are interested in also ramping up in
blockchain crypto applications any of
that you know go back to my early
getting up commits and look at my thanks
are there any other particular people
that you that you follow or look for
inspiration from or online resources of
courses like how does Bitcoin work on
YouTube and you'd find all kinds of very
basic conceptual cartoon diagrams all
the way to you know down the rabbit hole
cutting-edge cryptography other good
podcasts how about we talked about that
there's like a good business podcast the
unchained podcast from Laura Shin that's
a good one okay so another good one is
the off-the-chain podcast this is from
Anthony pump Leon oh I was just talking
about zero knowledge proof some moment
ago you did a great interview with the Z
cash founder a couple of weeks ago yeah
I highly recommend that one so you know
this stuff Laura is doing is more
business related and then pump is doing
some technical some business stuff yeah
those are those are both really really
good resources fantastic all right well
unfortunately we were starting to run
out of time a little bit but before we
do that is there anything you want to
mention any events or content that
you're pushing out that people should
hear about or know about or keep an eye
out for yeah I published a blog post
about three weeks ago that I wish I have
you could use aetherium which is a smart
contract platform special type of one of
these peer-to-peer networks to start
composing not only applications where we
can read and index and process the data
from the blockchain on cloud but how to
call out to cloud from the block
J so we were talking earlier about
biomedical analyses and not having the
kind of right architecture on chain to
be able to do the computing efficiently
as efficiently as a centralized cloud
provider but there's some way that you
can do this if you can call to the cloud
from the blockchain so this is sort of
become circular so we can index data
from the chain into Google Cloud and
then call to Google cloud from the chain
to get data back absolutely mind-blowing
how in Hobday you've been blowing my
mind and it's amazing thank you yeah so
it's always said I wrote an article
about their beast of a building these
hybrid cloud blockchain applications
that I think would be really interesting
if people want to see what cutting edge
stuff is going on excellent well Alan
thank you so much for joining us today I
definitely learned a lot and now I'll
maybe make slightly less jokes about
Pilar thank you so much Island I learned
so much I really appreciate this I now
feel like I might actually vaguely know
what blockchain vaguely is now it's a
great teacher now I have a much better
understanding so I feel really good
about that it blew my mind is the wide
range of applications it's used for not
just money not just cryptocurrency yeah
exactly
fantastic all right why don't we get
stuck into our question of the week
[Music]
okay so what are the four types of
virtual machines that exist on Google
cloud platform actually realize that
were that many so Google cloud is trying
to make things simple and efficient so
they came up with four different types
of VMs for different types of
applications so it's easy to remember it
if you think about the types of
applications so they have a general
purpose one for most types of
applications and it's called general
purpose VMs then they have memory
optimized VMs for large database
in-memory databases they have compute
optimized for like intensive gaming and
scientific modeling and then my last and
favorite type are called preemptable VMs
and so these are really affordable
they're gonna be like 80% of the cost
and they're just a flag that you can add
to any of the other three types to say I
don't need these to run in real time so
you can pre up me at any time and run
other applications as long as this runs
at some time and so those are great for
like batch rendering or assimilations
that don't need to be done in real time
so really don't we kind of have six then
we've got three the same ones and then
there each one of them can be
preemptable rather than four I mean that
is logical yes it's fine it's fine it's
fine there's a trick question I love it
all right just just thinking it through
it's fine cool but now that's great good
to know that we have different types of
machine types for different kind of
workloads so thank you very much Carter
you're welcome
so actually Carter where are you gonna
be like what are you doing what cool
stuff you're doing I know you're doing
cool stuff yeah all right so outside of
work something cool is I mean a Comedy
Festival the Edinburgh Fringe comedy
festival for a whole month
Google's letting me work from there for
a month it'd be really cool and
work-wise I'm releasing a bunch of
videos about vm's and GCE cloud security
command center so there's a lot of cool
stuff coming out check out the GCP
YouTube page you can see a lot of it
there awesome those videos sound great
but I think more importantly so you're
actually doing a show at the Edinburgh
Fringe Festival I am I'm doing a comedy
show I'm terrified because it's my first
time doing a show at this scale in this
level yeah yeah but you know it's a lot
of fun and again I'm just happy like I'm
at a place like Google that allows me
the flexibility to go out and try this
you know that's it working oh yeah it's
really cool that sounds fantastic well
I'm not doing anything nearly that
exciting I've gotta be at Tokyo next I
will be talking at the inside and apps
mini conference inside of
take your next talking about a gun is
game stuff then I'll be the
open-sourcing gaming day just before the
open source summit down in San Diego and
I'll be at the open source summit as
well talking about open source in games
and agonies and then I'll be a pax dev
speaking about now actually not a gun is
this time I'm actually doing two
separate panels doing one panel with a
bunch of colleagues talking about open
sourcing games and if that's something
you might be interested in and like why
you might want to do it and like that
kind of stuff and then I'm also doing
another panel with some other colleagues
talking about dedicated game servers why
you might want to use them and patents
therein and I'll also be hanging out of
pax West 8 which goes oh that's cool
I'm definitely have to pick your brain
about open sourcing games I didn't know
that was a thing trying to make it a
thing
trying to work really hard there's a lot
of work that's happening inside open
sourcing games but I think there's a lot
of work still to be done
mmm fantastic well Carter thank you so
much for joining me this week on the
podcast thank you for having me it was a
blast yeah I look forward to having you
as a regular host and I'm sure we'll
make this happen again at some point
soon oh great Iowa see you soon mark
wonderful well thank you all for
listening and we'll see you all next
week
[Music]